[Music]
did you know you can learn a lot about
how smart artistic social and confident
you are through a series of pictures if
you're ready to learn more about
yourself please hit the subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up
we'll run you through some questions
that will help you determine what kind
of personality you really have the
vanity photo Paula's vanity is a photo
drawn by artist Charles Alan Gilbert in
the late 1800s and it can tell a lot
about your personality when you look at
this picture what's the first thing you
see if the first thing you notice is the
woman in the mirror it means you're a
very romantic person but you could be
suffering from a lack of self-confidence
if you saw the skull first it means
you're a rebel and you love to live life
on the edge scenic picture in this
artwork what's the first image your eyes
are drawn to if you first noticed the
face it means you're a very creative
person and you love things that are
colorful and beautiful if you saw the
rocky cliff first it means your emotions
are always up and down and you suffer
from mood swings if you saw the dog
first it means you're a social butterfly
with a lot of friends and many people
are drawn to your positive outlook on
life the spinning girl this image of the
spinning girl has been determining
people's personalities for years when
you look at this image do you see the
girl spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise if you see her spinning
counterclockwise it means you're very
organized and analytical in the way you
think if you see her spinning clockwise
it means you're very insightful and you
love anything related to art if you're
one of the few who can see her spinning
in both directions
it means you probably have a very high
IQ the Rorschach inkblots
the Rorschach test consists of a series
of ink blots that psychologists use to
determine a person's personality when
you look at this ink blot what's the
first thing you see if you see two
figures leaning forward it means you're
a very patient person who's constantly
thinking if you see a racing car babies
Devils or two Cubs it means you have a
very vivid imagination if you see a
dentist's chair it means you're very
generous to those in your life but
you're also a very sensitive person if
you see a woman lying down it means
you're very easily
drafted and if you see two figures about
to invade another figure it means you
start a lot of projects but you have
trouble completing them pick one image
there are many images in this photo but
which image stands out the most is if
the moon and the light on the water the
person surfing or the whale if you first
notice the whale it means you're very
inquisitive when it comes to thinking
about your purpose in life if you saw
the moon and the light on the water
first it means you're extremely
optimistic and if you saw the person
surfing it means you're full of
confidence and you remain level-headed
no matter what situation you're in
crocodile abode or mountains in this
next image what do you see do you see
mountains and water people on a boat or
a crocodile if you see mountains and
water it means you have a lot of friends
and people generally like you if you see
people on a boat it means you're very
social and you love being in group
settings if you see a crocodile it means
to have a very wild imagination in slod
we have another ink blot from the
Rorschach test
what do you see this time around if you
see someone sticking out their tongue or
clown face it means you have a very
active social life if you see a lady
above dolphins it means you're very
charismatic and if you see a plush and
cuddly toy it means you have the
tendency to always dwell on the past
apples butterfly or knife in the next
photo do you see an apple a butterfly or
a knife if you see an apple it means you
have the ability to turn a negative
situation into a positive if you see a
butterfly it means you have a healthy
range of emotions enter a very stable
person if you see a knife it means
you're very adventurous and you're
always down to have a good time men
hidden inside coffee beans inside these
hundreds of coffee beans is the image of
a man's face can you see him the man's
face is located in the lower left-hand
corner if it took you three seconds or
less to spot him it means the right side
of your brain is very active this is the
side that's responsible for performing
creative and artistic tasks few images
in one in this photo do you see the
front of an old man's face or the back
of a woman's head if you saw the old
man's face first it means you're very
loyal and you're a natural-born leader
if you saw the woman's face first it
means you're full of positive energy and
you always remain
mystic and positive no matter what did
you learn anything new about yourself
after taking our personality test leave
us a comment down below and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
[Music]